[Applaudissements]
gérard g non non non voilées snella
batteux n'attendait pas il est toujours
à côté de la plaque et nous l'a prouvé
nous l'a prouvé dans l'émission parce
que il nous a prouvé
vous étiez producteur de musique voulait
toujours d'ailleurs vous sentez en
suspens de bientôt oui il n'ya pas que
ça vous êtes d'accord
vous êtes surpris complet barèges est
surpris du port ce qui nous a prouvé
qu'il avait une bonne oreille et
connaissait bien les chansons de
sébastien patoche oui on écouter la
chanson de sada ça patauge c'est le
panard écouter
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est balla maintenant
c'est le banana
[Musique]
c'est pas d'âme c'est pas d'âme
la louve est chaud c'est pas grave